J you look like an Eskimo so we just it
is called we just left when he college
who was playing cowboys against the
Detroit great game we throw out here
with the Cowboys private plane that they
have and had a good time but you know
what's funny is while we were here we
went to the Ford museum yesterday and if
you've never been it's absolutely
amazing what was it one of the areas was
nine and a half acres another one is
ninety acres you get a chance to see how
they make the Ford f-150 just an
incredible property and I'm asking
everybody locally but we were having
dinner last night at row store we went
out to see the city how the city feels
about Ford Motor Company and how they
feel about Henry Ford and there's a lot
of obviously different conversations
about the person who came into the city
and changed the game and created a
company employed so many people work you
work for Ford you're pretty much said in
this city here the moral of the story is
this here's what the message is when you
go in the museum and you look through
Henry Ford was everything he did he saw
things from a lens of how can I do this
better
meaning how can I build this better how
can I solve this problem one of the
games I play in my own mind and with
people around me as the following game
maybe I oughta try playing this game
this week here's what it is
no matter where you go restaurant
business city sports team no matter
where you go what you do
ask yourself if I ran this business what
would I do differently where's the leak
in this business where's an area where
they're leaving a lot of money on the
table where's there an opportunity here
for me to build it better for me to do
it better and just exercise that you
should use that with the people that
around you hey how would you run a
better in this restaurant here what do
you think they're like you like about
what they're doing here and get into
that mental state up doing it better
because that's what a lot of these guys
like Henry Ford then I think about it
this way one guy changed the entire city
we're in thirties forties fifties I want
to say till sixties Detroit was known as
the richest city in America until the
holes you know things change 70s was
still good 80s was still good and then
an ass that came out of Detroit changed
because free trade not cars were being
built in other parts of the world
instead of America cars will be built in
Mexico but the moral of the story is one
person changed the city of Detroit one
he owned the land this place called
Hinds Park and at one point he's like I
want to give this land to the city with
one disclaimer they said what is it you
can never build anything on top of this
I want this thing to be a party and then
you look at the last name you know you
go to this museum there's just painting
on the wall and it's got numbers of
everybody that was in that meeting that
took place I think in the 30s
Rockefeller Edison Hoover Mary Curie all
these people that were there what
happened
one person did it one person did it and
that one person can be you and your
family business can change the city can
change the last thing you can change
country you can change them every single
thing you want but it starts with one
person it was a dreamer who has a lens
that looks at everything saying what can
I do to make this thing better you can
do that test it out this week it's my
challenge of the week - you have a
killer week and stay tuned for some big
things coming out soon take - everybody
bye bye